[Musique]
cette 78e édition du paris-nice par
depuis le 78 depuis les yvelines cette
année c'est la commune de plaisir qui a
été choisie pour être la première étape
de l'épreuve
une édition 2020 un peu particulière
dans les yvelines l'actualité sanitaire
du moment rattraper la course cette
équipe ont déclaré forfait juste avant
le début de l'épreuve à cause du corolla
virus il a fallu prendre tout un tas de
mesures faire tout un tas de deux
chamboulement donc on a une une semaine
dernière très très très agitée là on
n'est pas encore sera 100% donc on sait
que qu'il faut vivre au jour le jour
mais on fait le maximum on prend des
mesures
ouais ya quelques règles quelques règles
différentes voilà on n'a pas trop droit
sinon au total 17 équipes ont pris le
départ de l'épreuve ce dimanche 8 mars
les organisateurs avaient concocté une
boucle de 154 km dans les yvelines en
passant par montfort l'amaury touahri ou
encore neauphle-le-château on a fait un
parcours avec des changements de
direction constants on sait à peu près
depuis depuis quelques années que
qu'il ya cette époque de l'année il ya
beaucoup de vent donc on essaye de
mettre les coureurs en difficulté et on
avait aussi pas mal de petites
grimpettes sympathique c'est finalement
le champion d'allemagne maximilian
sharman qui s'impose sur la ligne
d'arrivée à plaisir bien sûr je suis
très heureux c'est ma première fois ici
sur cette course c'était génial
le chouchou du public français julian
alaphilippe termine lui 4e je suis
content d'avoir fait un beau final la
peine qu'on soit vigilant dans les
bordures
[Musique]
après une très belle première étape un
plaisir aujourd'hui à le départ sera
donné depuis un chevreuil une petite
commune de moins de 6000 habitants
direction le loiret pour une étape de
166 km
oui
[Musique]
je suis avec madame le maire de
chevreuse madame le maire j'imagine que
vous êtes ravi d'accueillir ce
paris-nice ici assez fabuleux pour une
commune comme la nôtre c'est vraiment un
honneur et puis c'est vraiment un moment
génial à partager avec tous les
bénévoles tous ceux qui sont motivés
pour cette organisation on est vraiment
ravis et fiers d'accueillir le paris
nice où et quand ça se prépare justement
par une liste dans une ville alors c'est
un petit peu compliqué parce que vous
voyez notre commune c'est une rue
principale et si elle est complètement
bloquée donc pas mal d'organisation en
amont les écoles les transports etc
le stationnement mais tout ça c'est
vraiment anticiper les le travail a été
fait depuis le mois de décembre
maintenant et je pense qu'on est à peu
près près et voilà tout va bien se
passer on est on est vraiment ravis
heureux c'est une petite commune de
moins de 6000 habitants qui va être
connus au niveau mondial maintenant
alors j'espère qu'elle l'était déjà un
on a plein d'atouts qui font qu'on
devait déjà être connue donc j'espère
que ce sera juste une confirmation qu à
chevreuse ont fait une belle chose et
qu'on est ravi d'accueillir du public
pour des événements comme ça comme pour
notre et les spectateurs sont venus en
nombre autour de la ligne de départ ils
étaient plusieurs centaines de curieux
amateurs ou non de cyclisme je suis pas
mal de courses belgique jeu gars de
liège malgré la pluie
aujourd'hui on a du soleil c'est
on sait pas quand on est fan de
chevreuse et moins dans le vélo et je
viens toujours voir épargner se regarde
toujours mais ma télé mais leur succès
des paroles chevreuse c'est mieux on
voit tout le monde on voit les voitures
les vélos la ville de chevreuse et la
19e ville d'eysines à être village de
départ de l'épreuve
si vous regardez bien c'est aussi la
tendance même sur le tour de france
organisateur ce non pas ceux force mais
on peut grand plaisir à aller dans des
communes et ce pas seulement dans les
grandes villes
c'est plutôt sympa bien sûr c'est le
vélo c'est le sport de tout le monde
le départ a été donné à 12h25 sous les
applaudissements de la foule et des
enfants de la commune présent pour
l'événement
direction le loiret un pour les coureurs
rendez vous aux liens les prochaines
départ depuis les yvelines en 2021